well I I came to New York wanting to
work in the theater and I got a job as a
receptionist in the dimeric office and
David marks former casting director
Linda Otto was going to work for Marion
it was in 1968 you know one wanted to
make a movie in New York before then
because the unions were you know was
just so expensive that it was
prohibitive and but then when John
Lindsay came in it became affordable to
make movies in New York and everyone
went to Marion she had been she's done
live TV and obviously it was just such
an amazingly original thinker and had
done started off careers of people like
you know James Dean and Rod Steiger and
so forth and and she she was so
incredibly original in every way I mean
starting first of all no one in the film
business or business or in the theater
business had an office outside of
Midtown film was pretty much on 57th
Street and the theater in Times Square
and she and her husband found this
brownstone in you know an East 30th
Street and they totally renovated
themselves Marion hung all the wallpaper
and because she wanted to create an
environment that was going to be a
gracious environment for a process that
she thought was very painful for a lot
of people and it was very interesting
because she really trained us to be very
considerate of actors and to give them
the most information we possibly could
about what they should expect in the
interview and it about the script and
but she also was very sensitive to the
fact that directors came from all over
the world and that they were working out
of context as well and that they needed
us to give them a lot of information
about the actors they were seeing this
because they hadn't seen them in plays
or they hadn't necessarily you know
experienced any of their work before so
she taught us a kind of graciousness I
think about the process that having been
said she was a really an interesting
woman
because you know I think some
experienced er is formidable she was
sort of a you know chain-smoking kind of
arms akimbo kind of tough gal a little
profane sometimes and but she was at the
truth of it she was just a darling
darling person and very maternal and you
know she she really considered those of
us have worked for her Nessa Hyams and
Wally Necedah and questioned Rennell and
me her daughter she would call us her
daughters and I think she she really
meant it and she gave us an enormous
amount of responsibility within her
office and and kind of selflessly
allowed us to do movies independently
which built our confidence and and we're
really you know invaluable to our future
careers well tell us about one of the
first films you were done there oh well
I remember I remember when I arrived I
was 22 years old and I was a little
scared of Mary and I have to say at
first she always took a little wild
before she trusted new people and she
was doing Midnight Cowboy and I remember
reading the script and there was a role
of a prostitute and I in my little sort
of pea brain thought of with them the
most stereotypical
idea of what that prostitute might be
like you know and Marian called in these
really interesting I remember she called
in Salome gems and probably there's some
people who are too young to know who
Salome chance is but she was tall and
soft 'ok yes but a much more complex and
substantial person ID than i ever
pictured and she she just always it's a
little bit like what was discussed of
about Lynne stone master she she was
very original she was very selective she
she felt she had to kind of almost train
directors not to expect her to bring in
more than two or three people for a role
and that they all would be different
would not just bring in three identical
prostitutes you know they were
everything every single one would bring
something different she always brought a
different dimension to things